let's start by celebrating our zip code
of the day it's
33172 miami florida
which i'm guessing has really nice
weather right now
and one of our local cbs affiliates wfor
cbs4
miami was founded in 1896 by julia
tuttle
and she is the only women
woman excuse me in the united states
known for having founded a major city
go julia exactly and with more than 50
underwater rec sites for scuba
enthusiasts to explore miami once was
nicknamed recreational
wreck-relational diving capital of the
world miami florida i want to hear from
you does anyone have time to put pen to
paper and send us some mail i'll open
your letter
all right
in fact we're going to open our first
letter right now
oh look how creative and cute it says oh
my goodness
um all right uh dear drew i recently
watched never been kissed
thanks even though i'm not in high
school yet oh
two more years i still really enjoyed it
i have a few questions i wanted to ask
why did you want to play josie and after
playing her did you find a little bit of
you in her well
uh i love watching your segments with
jonah oh
maeve in connecticut
maeve the reason i wanted to do never
been kissed was because we all have a
little josie grossi inside of us
and we all feel awkward and we all want
to fit in
and we admire a group of people and
wonder if we can see ourselves in it or
if they'll let us in and we put so much
value in those other people
and a long life you learned that you
have to accept yourself and you'll find
your pod
you really will in these days but you
will find your group and um so yeah
there's me and her and her and me for
sure and thank you for writing in maeve
oh and she sent me some leaves too from
her yard
maeve i am into you
i feel you
and i'm gonna put this on my wall
and um i'll send you a picture of it
okay letter number two
oh
it's a gift oh my goodness oh and
poppies okay oh what is
this what pre-tell
dear drew the other day i noticed you
were having a hard time eating a bowl of
soup so i am sending a bowl cozy i made
place the bowl inside of it and it will
insulate your hands from hot or cold i
use mine when i eat ice cream deanna cox
greenup illinois
deanna
all i can say is that you really see me
and my style and the next time we're in
the kitchen please watch because i am
going to feature your bowl cozy thank
you so much deanna keep watching you're
going to see this and thank you for
helping me okay our third letter
all right we have time for one more gosh
deanna
okay dear drew
i enjoy watching daily oh thank you by
the way i think you can see the josie
grocery coming out me i'm like oh
um i especially love how you reach out
to people who have unselfishly gone
above and beyond by giving back and
giving thanks thank you for noticing
that this show is really a platform for
everybody else and i wanted to tell you
about operation troop support it was
established in 2003 by retired air force
lieutenant colonel richard moody and his
wife christine
they send care packages to our deployed
troops unfortunately when kovitt hit all
fundraising events to bring postage
money for the care packages have been
cancelled and the cost to send a care
package is 17.20
so if you can find it in your heart to
help the american soldiers through
operation troop support they would
greatly appreciate it charlene potter
danvers massachusetts
charlene we appreciate our soldiers and
i thank them and we all do for their
service so we're going to donate a
thousand dollars so that they can get a
little something from home
thank you for bringing this to our
attention
and anyone else out there if you would
like a little advice a suggestion
of someone or something we can support
if you want to see me try something tell
me a joke send a picture
email no don't email me snail mail me
your questions requests photos heartfelt
funny stories just bring it i mean look
at deanna and her soup cozy and look at
maeve and her beautiful leaves i can't
wait to read more of your letters and
thank you charlene for bringing
operation troop support to our attention
thank you so much truly yours drew
[Music]
you